I have this article right here from
WebMD and the point of this isn't to
poke holes at WebMD I think they have
some great articles and they have some
great information on their site but what
I want to do here is is to think about
what a lot of articles you might read or
a lot of research you might read are
implying and to think about whether they
really imply what they claim to be
implying so this is from this is an
excerpt of an article and the title of
the article says eating breakfast may
beat teen obesity so they're there
already they're already trying to kind
of create this this this
cause-and-effect relationship there the
title itself says if you eat breakfast
eat breakfast
if you eat breakfast then you will
you're less likely or you won't be obese
you're not going to be obese so that the
title right there already sets up this
that eating breakfast maybe teen obesity
and then they tell us about the study in
the study published in Pediatrics
researchers analyzed the dietary and
weight patterns of a group of 2216
adolescents over a five-year period from
public schools in Minneapolis st. Paul
Minnesota and I won't talk too much
about this looks like a good you know
sample size it was over a large period
of time I'll just give the researchers
to benefit the doubt assume that it was
it was over a broad audience that they
were able to control for a lot of
variables but then they go on to say the
research is right that teens who ate
breakfast regularly had a lower
percentage of total calories from
saturated fat and ate more fiber and
carbohydrates and to some degree that
first then those who skipped breakfast
and to some degree this first sentence
is obvious breakfast
tends to be things like cereals grains
you know you eat syrup you eat waffles
that all tends to fall in the category
of carbohydrates and sugars and frankly
that's not even necessarily a good thing
not obvious to me whether bacon is more
or less healthy than downing a bunch of
syrup or Froot Loops or whatever else
but we'll let that be right here in
addition regular breakfast eaters seemed
more physically active than their
breakfast skippers so over here they're
once again trying to create this other
cause-and-effect relationship
regular breakfast eaters seemed more
physically active than their breakfast
Gator skippers so the implication here
is that breakfast that breakfast
breakfast makes you makes you more
active and then this last sentence right
over here they say overtime
researchers found teens who regularly
ate breakfast tended to gain less weight
and had a lower body mass index than
breakfast skippers so you could in
they're telling us that breakfast
breakfast skipping this is the
implication here breakfast skipping is
more likely or it can be a cause of
making you overweight or maybe even
making you obese so the entire narrative
here from the title all the way through
every paragraph is look breakfast
prevents obesity breakfast makes you
active breakfast skipping will make you
obese oh you just say that boy I have to
eat breakfast and you should always
think about the motivations and the
industries around things like breakfast
but the more interesting question is
does this research really tell us that
eating breakfast can prevent obesity
does it really tell us that breakfast
eating breakfast will cause something to
become more active or does it really
tell us that breakfast skipping can make
you overweight or make it obese or is
more likely are they just showing that
these two things tend to go together and
this is a really important difference
and let me let me kind of state slightly
technical words here but and they sound
fancy but they really aren't that fancy
are they pointing out causality are they
pointing out causality which is what it
seems like they're implying eating
breakfast causes you to not be obese
breakfast causes you to be active
breakfast skipping causes you to be
obese so it looks like they are the kind
of implying causality they're implying
cause and effect but really what the
study looked at is correlation is
correlation so we're really the whole
point of this is to understand the
difference between causality and
correlation because they're saying very
different things causality versus
correlation causality versus correlation
and as I said causality says a causes B
while correlation just says a and B tend
to be observed at the same time whenever
I see B happening it looks like a is
happening at the same time whenever a is
happening it looks like it also tends to
happen with B and the reason why it's
super important to notice the
distinction between these is you can
come to very very very very different
conclusions
so the one thing that this research does
do assuming that it was performed well
is it does show a correlation so this
study does show correlation it does show
if we believe all of their data that
breakfast skipping correlates with
obesity and obesity correlates with
breakfast skipping we're seeing it at
the same time activity correlates with
breakfast and breakfast correlates with
activity that all of these correlate
what they don't say what and there's no
data here that lets me know one way or
the other what is causing what or maybe
you have some underlying cause that is
causing both so for example they're
saying breakfast causes activity or
they're implying breakfast causes
activity they're not saying it
explicitly explicitly but maybe activity
causes breakfast maybe they didn't they
didn't write the study that people who
are active maybe they're more likely to
be hungry in the morning activity
activity causes breakfast and then you
start having a different takeaway then
you don't say wait if if I maybe if
you're active and just get breakfast and
I'm not telling you that you should I
have no data want to do that maybe you
leave a little you'll lose even more
weight maybe it's even a healthier thing
to do we're not sure so they're trying
to say look if you have breakfast it's
going to make you active which is a very
positive outcome but maybe you can have
the positive outcome without breakfast
who knows likewise they say breakfast
skipping or they're implying breakfast
skipping can cause obesity but maybe
it's the other way around maybe people
who have a high body fat maybe for
whatever reason they're less likely to
get hungry in the morning so maybe maybe
maybe it goes this way maybe there's a
causality there or even more likely
maybe there's some underlying cause that
causes both of these things to happen
and you could think of a bunch of
different examples of that one could be
one could be the physical activity so
physical activity and these are all just
theories I have no proof for it but I
just want to give you different ways of
thinking about the same data and maybe
not just coming to the same conclusion
that this article is it seems like it's
trying to lead us to conclude that we
should eat breakfast if we don't want to
become obese so maybe if you're
physically active that leads maybe maybe
when you are physically active that
leads for you leads to you being hungry
in the morning so you're more likely to
eat breakfast and obviously being
physically active also
makes it so that you you burned calories
you have more muscle so that you're
you're not obese you are not obese so
notice this isn't if you view things
this way if you say physical activity is
causing both of these then all of a
sudden you lose this connection between
breakfast and obesity now you can't make
the claim that if if that somehow Matt
breakfast is the magic is the magic is
the magic formula for someone to not be
obese so let's say that there is an
obese person let's say this is the
reality that physical activity is
causing both of these things and let's
say that there is an obese person what
will you tell them to do will you tell
them eat breakfast and you won't become
obese anymore well that might not work
especially if they're not physically
active I mean what's going to happen if
you have an obese person who is not
physically active not physically not
physically active and then you tell them
to eat breakfast maybe that'll make
things worse and based on that that the
advice or the implication from from the
article is the wrong thing physical
activity maybe is the thing that should
be focused on maybe something other than
physical activity maybe you have maybe
you have sleep maybe people who sleep
late sleep late and they're not getting
enough sleep not enough there's not
enough sleep maybe someone who's not
getting enough sleep maybe that leads to
obesity and obviously because they're
not getting enough sleep they wake up as
late as possible and they have to run to
the next appointment and or they have to
run to school in the case of students
and maybe that's why they skip for
breakfast maybe that's why they skip
breakfast so once again if you if you
find someone obese maybe the rule here
isn't to force a breakfast down your
throat maybe it'll become even worse
because maybe it is the lack of sleep
that's causing your metabolism to slow
down or whatever so it's very very
important when you're looking at any of
these studies to try to say is this a
correlation or is this a is this
causality if it's correlation you cannot
make the judgment that hey eating
breakfast is necessarily going to make
someone less obese all that tells you is
that these things move together a better
study would be one that is able to prove
causality and then we could think of
other other underlying underlying causes
that would kind of break down the narrow
that this that this piece is trying to
say I'm not saying it's wrong
maybe it's absolutely true that eating
breakfast will fight obesity but I think
it's equally or more important to think
about what the other causes are not to
just make a blanket statement like that
so for example maybe maybe poverty
maybe poverty causes you to skip a
breakfast for multiple reasons maybe
you're both of your parents are working
there's no one there to give you
breakfast maybe there's more stress than
the fit who knows what it might be and
so when you have when you have poverty
maybe you're more likely to skip
breakfast and maybe when there's poverty
and maybe you have too both your parents
are working and the kids have to make
their own dinner and whatever else maybe
they also eat less healthy so eat less
healthy eat less healthy at all times of
day at all times a day and then that
leads to obesity so once again in this
situation if this is the reality of
things just telling someone to also eat
breakfast regardless of what that
breakfast is even if it's you know fruit
loops or syrup that's probably not going
to help the situation maybe it's maybe
it's just you know eating unhealthy
dinners maybe eating unhealthy dinners
is the underlying cause
unhealthy dinner and if you eat an
unhealthy dinner maybe by breakfast time
you you're not hungry still because you
binge so much on breakfast so you skip
breakfast and this also leads to obesity
but once again if this is the actual
reality doing the advice that that
articles saying might actually be a bad
thing if you eat an unhealthy dinner and
then force yourself to eat a breakfast
when you're not hungry that might make
the obesity even worse so the whole
point of this video isn't to say that
the implications from that article are
necessarily wrong that the important
thing is to just realize that it might
be wrong and that just because you saw
this correlation with the data it
doesn't mean that eating breakfast is
going to somehow magically fight obesity